[Musique]
tour sa cathédrale et son grand théâtre
cet énorme vaisseau de culture semble
être depuis toujours posé là amarré aux
toits de la ville
[Musique]
il y à au moins deux façons de pénétrer
dans ce temple de l'opéra et de la
musique par la grande porte majestueuse
avec cet escalier monumental si typique
de l'architecturé du 19e siècle
et puis il y à cet autre entrée plus
discrète à l'arrière du bâtiment qui
donne sur une petite cour modeste et
soigneusement caché à la vue du public
d'ici on voit la majorité des activités
de préparation d'activités parallèles ce
que le spectateur ne voit pas et ne doit
pas voir
[Musique]
nous voici au coeur des ateliers c'est
là que sont fabriqués tous les éléments
de décor ici on soude
on découpe on perd son ensemble ont
peint tour est l'un des derniers opéras
de province a disposé à six de ces
ateliers sur son site historique
alors évidemment l'exiguïté des lieux
pose parfois quelques problèmes de
manipulation mais la situation présente
aussi de sérieux avantages
les machinistes constructeur de l'opéra
de tours asie ce aussi bien sur scène en
manipulation de décor que en atelier en
création de décors donc cette
polyvalence elle se traduit très
concrètement par une meilleure gestion
ergonomique de la fabrication puisque
les gens qui fabriquent les éléments
savent c'est eux qui vont les manipuler
l'un des peintres décorateurs réalise un
faux marbre pour la future tosca vue de
la salle l'illusion sera parfaite
y'a pas un projet scénographique qui
ressemble à un autre
donc on refait on ne refait jamais
quasiment la même chose du d'un ouvrage
lyrique à un autre donc voilà c'est
aspect 2 mai de curiosité puis
d'innovation à chaque fois c'est c'est
la partie des parties les plus
intéressantes du travail quoi
mais quittons un instant le grand
théâtre quelque part en périphérie de la
ville
nous découvrons cette immense hangar
[Musique]
les décors et accessoires d'une
vingtaine d'opérations stockés derrière
vous cosi fan tutte juste ici bérénice
appel mais joey joie certes certains
éléments de macbeth bon voila j'ai vu un
mozart là bas ces décors qui nous ont
fait rêver nous les retrouverons demain
sur une autre scène pour présenter une
autre oeuvre avec d'autres métiers tout
aussi important
c'est grâce au rôle propre à chacun que
le spectacle peut trouver toute sa magie
très bas
[Musique]
il flotte comme un parfum de naphtaline
au fond de ce couloir dans cette salle
plus de 5000 éléments de costumes sont
délicatement aligner capitaine femmes du
monde jeune bourgeois ou enfants des
rues ils sont tous là au garde à vous
reflet d'une époque où d'une société il
témoigne en tout cas de la longue
histoire de l'opéra de tours mais déjà
il faut préparer les prochains modèles
alors là c'est la reine caroline c'est
pour le td homs après une figurante qui
portera secours tu l'as dans le thé des
hommes chanter avec le coeur et c'est là
nous avons cardinal sur pareil avec les
normes cap comme ça donc il ya aussi
beaucoup de costumes dans cet ouvrage
qui ont été récupérés d'un ancien tosca
donc on fait des costumes 9 mais on a
aussi essayé de récupérer les costumes
aux stocks nous en trou dans l'atelier
de couture
ici c'est le royaume des petites mains
[Musique]
cinq à dix derrière
on avait une fiche de mesure des
artistes et on fait les costumes on
coupe les costumes aux mesures des
artistes après les artistes quand il
arrive au moment de la mise en scène ont
fait les essayages et entretenir les
costumes des costumes taillés tout
spécialement pour des chanteurs d'opéra
donc une vraie prouesse technique
dès qu'on veut fermer à col de chemise à
un homme dans tout de suite ils
étouffent avant d'avoir fermé donc on
met quatre tailles au dessus voilà on
absolument pas serrer le cou pour les
garçons et pour les femmes au niveau de
vie vante cetera il faut certes personne
ne sut pas d'être serrée d'autres non et
puis aussi des mouvements parce que
lorsqu'on doit lever le bras etc
il faut pas être coincé par une aventure
dont il ya des astuces de costumier
c
[Musique]
alors quand on voit sur scène les
costumes que l'on à réaliser soi même on
ressent une certaine fierté
mais pas seulement on est heureux on est
ému en
et on a l'oeil très technique la
première fois qu'on le voit donc on fait
passer de l'opéra du coup direction la
salle d'essayage
il règne ici une sorte de fébrilité
soudanais tableau on mettra une calotte
noire un art aux clés à l'or et romane
sont de jeunes recrues issues du
conservatoire
c'est leur toute première expérience
scénique c'est trop cool et tant pis
pour les costumes de princesse pour la
tosca c'est un enfant de coeur qu'elle
apparaît trop
[Musique]
notre guide nous entraîne à présent dans
les entrailles de l'opéra cette forêt de
poutres rempli son office depuis
l'origine du grand théâtre soit presque
un siècle et demi à soutenir des
représentations nous sommes ici sous la
scène neuf mètres de haut réparties sur
trois niveaux
cet espace compliquer une fonction très
précises il sert à aménager des
apparitions scéniques voilà en volume ou
des toiles ou des personnes avec une
apparition sociaux une trappe à tampon
ça se fait fréquemment d'étagé en étage
d'escalier en coursive
nous montons à présent au cinquième
niveau dans ce qu'on appelle les cintres
ici en fait on procède de levage des
décors en hauteur donc ça s'appelle
cintrier voilà est donc là pour vous
donner un exemple
il m'a donné deux m'a demandé de lui
chargé c'est à dire de faire charger
c'est descendre un décor pour se pencher
nous est appuyé c'est leur montée en
fait pour le dissimuler derrière des
frises ça fait un peu penser au système
salut à tous les systèmes de
marin sont les bateaux il ya tous les
fils pour pourtant d'étendre les voiles
et sauf que là on est sur un système
bâtiment plus moderne qu'un bateau le
cintrier est en contact étroit avec la
régie lumière 18 mètres plus bas
derniers réglages des éclairages
pendant ce temps les solistes de l'homme
de la mancha prennent un moment pour se
concentrer dans leur loge chercher des
trésors là où se trouve que l'amour
n'est ce pas pure folie et la folie
suprême n'était elle pas de voir la vie
telle qu'elle est et non telle qu'elle
ne va être le grand théâtre de tours
ils en connaissent déjà pour la plupart
les charmes et c'est avec la taille
humaine et à chaleur humaine surtout
pour ce genre d'oeuvre je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir quelque chose de
chaleureux une belle salle comme celle
ci c'est malgré tout un très très jeune
et théâtre on est très très bien reçus
c'est très important pour nous parce
qu'on est comme je dis d'e.on et des
itinérants on est des nomades et pour
nous le théâtre la maison ducasse et
c'est la maison c'est là où on va passer
la plupart du temps et donc on a besoin
de bien s'y sentir il reste encore
quelques jours avant les premières
représentations devant le public alors
pour l'instant les répétitions c'est
sans costumes et avec un piano pour tout
orchestre
je suis sincèrement navré d'avoir
quelque peu perturbé votre avis
ouais vous redescendez là comme ça vous
la regardez vous n'êtes pas derrière un
voile à un peu plus serré à le groupe un
peu plus compact voilà comme ça un peu
d'eau d'ajustement en précision le
spectacle prend forme pour la prochaine
étape tous les artistes seront réunis
sur la scène et dans la fosse
[Musique]
à
et chaque métier a son propre tempo
quand les uns affine les réglages du
prochain opéra d'autres s'attèle déjà et
suivant dans la salle dite des choeurs
les sopranos et les ados s'activent au
programme des world jacques massey la
tosca de puccini
[Musique]
merci beaucoup oui c'est pas mal du tout
madame on a globalement d'un pop soul du
tempo on est un tout petit peu derrière
du coup ça a du mal à avancer faut
contraindre peu dynamique quand le coeur
devient un personnage à part entière
l'aider à s'harmoniser à trouver sa
couleur d'ensemble c'est l'un des rôles
d' alexandre herviant le jeune chef de
choeur landais nouvellement arrivé à
tours
il faut qu'ils rassemblent un peu le
berger c'est un effectif assez réduit
finalement ce qu'on se retrouve à 13
chanteurs donc c'est en moyenne entre
trois et quatre chanteurs par voie donc
c'est vraiment un coeur un choeur de
chambre ce qu'on peut appeler un choeur
de chambre
ça représente vraiment la l'avantagent
de pouvoir faire un vrai travail de fond
très très très précise très exigeant que
le coeur aussi
[Musique]
changement d'étagé petit tour dans la
salle de danse c'est le tour qui voit
que du coup ça fait cette saison
position n'a pas ce qu'on fait les
artistes construisent leur chorégraphie
pas à pas on commence d'abord nous et
puis après on va en scène donc on voit
déjà l'espace avec le décor et puis
après on rajoute les costumes et puis
après on en rajoute et perruque à chaque
fois il ya un élément nouveau qui nous
donne aussi le temps de nous adapter à
chaque fois pour l'aboutissement final
nous retrouvons nos danseurs sur le
plateau ils seront bientôt rejoints par
les autres artistes pour une première
répétition générale avec cette fois-ci
costumes et orchestre le tout sous
l'oeil attentif du nouveau directeur des
lieux lui qui entend s'appuyer sur les
atouts de l'équipement tourangeau on a
la chance puisqu'on n'a pas de soliste
permanent de pouvoir inviter des
artistes
donc certains qui sont sur les plus
grandes scènes internationales et puis
aussi des artistes plus jeunes et on
pouvoir mélanger un petit peu ces
expériences différentes
sait on a moins de contraintes
apparemment que dans un dans une très
très grande maison type opéra national
et avec des enjeux plus importants
puisqu'on est le seul le seul outil
régional donc l' orchestre régional qui
est qui est subventionnée aussi par la
région à une très forte mission de
diffusion en dehors de la ville de
sièges qui tourne dans 5 minutes
navigation du début en cinq minutes la
figuration
l'énorme machinerie s'ébranle avec la
précision d'une horloge suisse dans
cette subtile mécanique où chaque pièce
trouve sa place réglez millimétré
solistes choristes danseurs musiciens et
techniciens nous offre éblouissement
d'été motion
[Musique]
ses 120 ans
six mois